I mean if you look on my Amazon reviews
loads of people clearly not read the
book giving it one star reviews saying
it's I'm Britain bashing yeah the book's
not out yet but that's great yeah
actually no the book got called vicious
brilliant in the Jewish Chronicle by a
right-wing journalist uh about three
months before I finished it so that's
what you're facing now I mean and you
know David audisoga has a bodyguard yeah
it's full-on culture wars it's actually
translating into actual it feels like
actual War sometimes and of course I'm
gonna get accused of that but I think
the if you understand Empire it's a
really positive thing overall you know
for a start a lot of British people took
on the Empire throughout
uh secondly yes we we you know dominated
the slave trade for large periods but
also we abolished it and I say that in
the book and then yeah we've got we have
racism which was created by Empire but
also we have a Multicultural Society
because of Empire those things can
co-exist the problem in the culture wars
is that there's no room for nuance but
you talk about coexistence and I wonder
if with this book what you're trying to
show kids is that you can be proud of
your country but also ask questions
about your country and that's what now
that's what it's equipping them to do
yeah if you love real say if you really
love your family I wrote a family Memoir
that was an expression of love I sat
there and sat through very difficult
stories things that pained me but it's
because I love my family that I thought
it was worthwhile similarly with your
country if you truly love your country
you look at the history warts and all to
understand it the proper truth rather
than seeing it through a prism of Pride
or shame which is bizarre because I mean
why would you view history through
feelings you're feeling really do not
matter and you would consider yourself a
patriot right yeah I mean I am way to
right away for some people you know by
saying things like that well on the
center is probably and you know what
it's this is all quite new I think
idea that uh you not you're not properly
British if you dare to observe the
massacres and the slaveries it's a
modern trope
and again created by social media I feel
interesting isn't it I mean I've seen
the kind of stuff that you get on social
media uh and it's interesting because
other uh historians who are not of color
who say similar things don't get any of
that they're certainly not walking
around with bodyguards do you ever think
actually it's too much yeah I do I
actually more or less stop doing events
in Britain because actually the trolling
online is I'm so used to it it doesn't
really matter it doesn't feel real
um although it does get you when it's
Relentless for days at a time when you
get targeted but it's the it's the way
it translates into real life it's people
coming to my events and shouting at me
and
you know when that happens
it always makes for a good event in the
sense that other people stand up for me
it feels like the whole event matters I
I sell out my books it's good I mean it
might probably it makes my publisher
happy but it comes a personal cost to me
I realized that I started dreading the
moment I was waiting to be attacked and
I just stopped doing those events and I
just did International ones but then I
did interview I did an event at Jaipur
where you were there and you know there
was a journalist who writes with a
telegraph who wrote a very completely
skewed version of what happened you just
can't escape it really but I'm now gonna
have to start doing these events and I
think I'm hoping the part of the
solution with stolen history is to talk
directly to schools and pupils I find
talking to students
is much more rewarding than talking to
imperily nostalgic adults who maybe had
a very one-sided education
I'm surprised to hear you say that you
don't
um what were you kind of
have tried to avoid events here I mean
you have not had death threats have you
you've not you don't have a bodyguard no
no I don't but enough
yeah I mean
it's quite I mean I'm not the only one I
do feel like uh black historians get it
worse and women women of color get it
absolutely the worst